okay real quick I don't want to spend a
ton of time on this but I want to just
show you that the Tucker Carlson Fox
news program has become a complete and
totally open platform
for conspiracy theories at this point in
time that that's all it is yesterday I
showed you how Tucker loves this Ray
Epps the FBI did the Trump riots
conspiracy theory and he used Ted Cruz
to push it he then had on uh Glenn Beck
who has covid right now and allowed
Glenn Beck to push the uh Washington
State covid internment camp conspiracy
theory if you haven't heard about it
I'll tell you about it in a moment the
great reset is not a conspiracy theory
it is something that the Davos people
have put together along with the world
economic forum and it is running rampant
through every Western capital and every
Western company country it is I just I
just read this tomorrow morning at 9 30.
uh the Washington State covid detainment
emergency they are going to have a State
Board of Health discussing from 9 30 to
3 30 tomorrow allowing Health local
Health officers to use law enforcement
to force an emergency order in
involuntarily detaining a person or
group of persons families to be isolated
in a quarantine facility following the
refusal to voluntarily comply with
request medical examinations testing
treatment by the way if you're not
watching Tucker's doing the confused
face the entire time here sling and
vaccination
this is an internment camp Washington
state has done it before they haven't
obviously learned their lesson from
World War II this again is all about
total and complete control now
everything Glenn Beck is saying is a lie
this has been widely debunked let me
tell you what's going on no writes KREM
Washington won't forcibly quarantine
those who have coveted or are
unvaccinated
the State Board of Health has received
thousands of emails about an agenda item
that will be discussed this week
claims are going around that Washington
politicians are trying to create laws
that would allow them to force
unvaccinated people into quarantine
the State Board of Health received
thousands of emails we set out to verify
claims the question does this proposal
allow Health officials to use law
enforcement to force an emergency order
to involuntarily detain a person or
group in a facility if they refuse to
comply with requests for medical
treatment testing treatment counseling
or vaccination the answer no the state
isn't trying to quarantine forcibly
those who have coveted or are
unvaccinated just to be really clear our
board meeting on Wednesday is there are
no conversations about isolation and
quarantine camps there are no rules
existing or in the making to create
isolation and quarantine camps
there are no rules and there is no
process in place to create a rule to
involuntary core involuntarily
quarantine or isolate covid-19 positive
people
regardless of vaccination there are no
laws and no plans to do it period it's
just bogus it's this is nothing there
and Tucker Carlson's Fox news program
which is I think at this point the most
widely listened to right-wing program
I I mean maybe Joe Rogan is considered a
right-wing program now and has a bigger
audience but it is one of the biggest
right-wing programs every day there's a
new conspiracy theory if you watch
Tucker and you accept the stuff on there
the feds did 911. uh I'm sorry the the
feds did the Trump riots not 911. maybe
they say the feds did 911 too I don't
know the the feds did the Trump riots is
what I mean
um and they're gonna in turn there's
gonna be an internment camp for people
with covid in Washington every day it's
a new conspiracy theory
extraordinarily dangerous stuff and if
you're just listening today we'll have
these clips up on our Instagram which
you can find at davidpackman show
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the David packman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app I just
listened to this is your mind on Plants
by the great Michael pollen super
interesting the history of caffeine and
so many other things blinkist has you
covered on podcast two blinkist takes
long episodes of popular podcasts and
distills them into audio you can listen
to and 15 minutes with blinkist you can
become knowledgeable about so many
different things you can have
conversations with people about more
topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded try blink is for free and
get 25 off a subscription go to
blinkist.com Pacman the link is down
below